[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM COIMBRA: Thank you.
Welcome.
We're super excited
to talk to you
about how to bring your
Android apps to the Assistant.
I'm Adam Coimbra.
I'm a product manager
on the Google Assistant.
ADAM KOCH: Hi everyone.
I'm Adam Koch.
I work on a developer
relations team at Google.
SOFIA ALTUNA: And I'm Sofia
Altuna from our product
partnerships team.
ADAM COIMBRA: So App
Actions is a simple way
to connect the seamlessness
of the Assistant
to your Android app.
Users can ask the Assistant
to do something, and Assistant
fast forwards into your
app into the right place.
So for example, instead of
tapping through your phone
when you just want to get
out the door and start a run,
you can just ask the
Assistant, hey, Google,
start my run with Nike.
And the system will
automatically open Nike's app
and start the run because
Nike implemented App Actions.
So last year, we presented
an ambitious vision
for App Actions, and
we've been working hard
to turn that vision
into a reality.
And so I'm really excited
that App Actions is now
available for apps in our
first four categories--
finance, fitness, food
ordering, and ride sharing.
Now if your app falls into
one of these categories,
you can start building
today and deploy your app
to be part of our consumer
launch later this year.
But taking a step back,
why extend your Android
app to the Assistant?
What's in it for you?
Well, we know that there are
challenges with re-engagement
for mobile apps.
And we think that part of that
is because there's friction
in the app experience today.
Users have 40 plus Android
apps on their devices.
And they need to remember all
of them, navigate between them,
navigate inside of them.
It's a lot to keep track of.
Meanwhile, Google
is working hard
to make Assistant the best
way to get things done.
And what's unique
about the Assistant
is that it allows
users to just express
what they want naturally rather
than worrying about what icon
to click.
And with the Assistant available
on nearly a billion Android
devices, this is a
great opportunity
to bring your app into
this new entry point.
You can leverage the Assistant
to bring our more natural
frictionless experience to your
own app and your own users.
This will become
even more powerful
with the next
generation Assistant
that we previewed
yesterday in the keynote.
It will unlock a much faster
and deeper Android experience
than ever, thanks to Google's
advances with on device AI.
But we know that
mobile apps will
continue to be the
foundation of how users
get things done in Android.
And so we envision a
seamless connection
with the mobile ecosystem
to be a key feature
of the next
generation Assistant.
And we're excited to
work with you to make
that happen via App Actions.
To recap, App Actions
in the Assistant
will provide a much more
natural way for your users
to access your apps.
Assistant's powerful NLU
handles the user request
and translates it into a
deep link into your app,
accelerating the user's journey.
Here's another example.
Let's say I just had
lunch with Sofia.
And I need to pay her back.
I can say send $15
to Sofia on PayPal.
And again, Assistant will
fast forward into PayPal.
But not only taking me to
the right place in the app,
but also passing the
parameters from my request
directly in, so, like,
the amount and the name.
That allows the user to
skip even more steps.
Now one of my favorite
parts about App Actions
is how simple it was for
Paypal to build that.
All they really needed to do
was expose existing deep links
in their app in a way that the
Assistant could semantically
understand.
Now this is enabled
by connecting together
two different
technologies that happen
to share the exact same name.
The first is Assistant
Built-In Intent.
So we are publishing a
catalog of semantic intents
that represent many,
many different requests
that a user might make.
Now as you can see on the
left, we have the Create Money
Transfer Assistant Intent.
This allows Assistant to resolve
that query, send $15 to Sofia.
Now you're probably
already familiar
with the second technology.
That's Android Intents,
which are used by many apps
for deep linking today.
As you can see on
the right, PayPal
has already implemented
their own deep linking scheme
for sending money
via Android Intents.
So to make this work, what
Paypal really needed to do
was add one file called
actions.xml to their Android
project that maps from the
Assistant Built-In Intent
to their existing
Android Intent.
So as you can see, the core
integration for App Actions
is very simple and
very easy to do.
Again, App Actions is available
right now for development.
If your app is in one of our
first four categories-- again,
finance, food ordering,
ridesharing, and fitness--
I really hope that
tonight you'll
come to visit our developer
documentation and start
building.
And we'd love to
have all your apps
as part of our consumer launch
in the next couple months.
And if your app isn't in one
of those first four categories,
stay tuned.
Because we'll be working on
new categories and intents
very soon.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
ADAM KOCH: Great.
So now you've
learned a little bit
about the background
behind App Actions.
I'm going to walk you through
the technical implementation.
I've broken the implementation
down into four key steps--
supporting deep links
in your Android app,
telling the Assistant how
to take advantage and use
those deep links,
optimizing your app further
for the Google
Assistant, and then
testing and deploying your
app actions to end users.
Before I get started,
I wanted to note
a few additional things.
First of all, implementation
for App Actions
happens completely from
within your Android code base.
In addition, as
much as possible,
we try to take advantage of
a lot of the existing APIs
and infrastructure that
Android already supports.
And then lastly, App
Actions runs anywhere
where the Google
Assistant runs on Android.
That's from Android
5.0 Lollipop and above.
OK.
Step 1, Android Deep Links.
For those of you who
aren't Android developers,
deep links are URLs
that take users directly
to specific content or
actions within an app.
The good news is most Android
developers have already
implemented deep links in some
shape or form in the Android
application.
So there may not be that
much work for you to do here.
However, we do recommend that
you review our App Actions
documentation,
understand the actions
and understand the
parameters that we require
for those actions, and make
sure that your deep links can
support them.
Here's a few deep
link URI examples.
The first kind of deep
links that we support
are Android app links
variety of deep links.
You can see an example of
an Android app links here.
It just looks like
a regular web URI--
HTTPS://mysite.com/example.
Android app links requires
that you verify ownership
of your domain name and also
your Android app and that
allows the Android
system to connect
through when one
of those web links
is encountered at
the system level.
Now this is the recommended
type, if possible.
However, we understand that
not all Android apps can
use these kinds of app links.
For example, if a particular
action doesn't have a web URL
equivalent, or some content
doesn't have a web URL
equivalent, you can use
something like custom scheme
deep links instead, like
you see at the bottom here.
Now I'm not going to go into
too much depth on deep links,
because they're a very
well-known Android technology
and they're documented on our
Android developer site already.
OK.
Moving along to Step 2,
telling the Assistant
how to use your application.
This is where we're
going to specify which
app actions that we
can support in the app,
as well as defining
something called
fulfillment URLs and the
parameters that we need.
Optionally, you can
specify something
called inline inventory and
I'll get into details on that
shortly.
OK.
So what are we going to do?
Go to our Android project
and create a new xml file
in our resources xml directory.
Let's call it actions.xml.
Then we're going to edit
our Android manifest file.
And we're going to add a
metadata tag with the name
com.google.android.actions.
And we're going to link
through to that xml file
that we created.
Let's have a look inside
the actions.xml file.
OK.
There's a lot to
take in here, so I'm
going to spend some time
working through this.
Because this is a really
key part of the App Actions
implementation.
First of all, at a
high level, you'll
see at the top we've
defined an actions block.
Within each actions
block, we can
have one or more action blocks.
And this is where we map
over to the App Action
that we want to support.
Within each action block,
we can define one or more
fulfillment mechanisms.
This is where we
define the deep links
that we can connect through
to our Android application.
And then finally, within
each fulfillment block,
we can define zero or more
parameter mapping blocks.
And this is where
we choose which
parameters from those
actions that we can support.
Now let's look at
the values that I've
set in this particular example.
First, I wanted to highlight
intent name and intent
parameter.
Now these values are pulled
directly from our developer
documentation.
So if you're wondering where
those values come from,
you have to go and copy them
directly from the developer
docs.
The intent name is the
name of the app action
you want to support.
In this case, we have defined
actions.intent.get exercise
observation.
Get exercise observation
is a fitness app action
where the user can ask the
app for additional information
on a particular
exercise activity.
For example, hey, Google, ask
Nike Run club how many miles
have I run today?
Moving down to the
parameter mapping blocks,
this is where we
define which parameters
we want to listen for
in our Android app.
You can see here that
we've defined two.
One is exerciseObservat
ion.aboutExercise.name.
This is going to map
over to the exercise
that the user is asking about,
for example, running or biking.
The second one we've
defined is exerciseObservat
ion.measuredProperty.name.
And this is going to map
over to the exercise property
that the user is asking about,
for example, distance, pace,
or calories.
Moving along, now I'm
highlighting the urlTemplate
and URL parameter values.
These values are completely
up to you to define.
The URL template is
going to be the deep link
through to your Android app.
You can see here, we've got
an HTTPS-style deep link,
which means it's an app
link style of deep link.
You'll also note
the curly braces
in the urlTemplate with
some parameter names.
And I'll walk through how
that works in just a second.
Then in the parameter
mapping blocks,
we've defined a
urlTemplate value
for each parameter mapping.
This is a name that
you want to give
to each of those parameters.
In this case, we've
given the simple names
of exercise and property.
And you'll see that those
same parameters appear back
in that urlTemplate.
OK.
But what is this urlTemplate
and how does it work?
Well, the urlTemplate value
follows the RFC6570 spec.
Great, right?
I wasn't familiar with that spec
before work on this project,
either.
But for most developers,
all you really need to know
is that those particular
parameters are going
to expand into
the parameter name
equals the parameter
value when it's
expanded from the template.
Let's look at this example.
So we've got our template at
the top here, like we defined.
Now the user may
say something like,
hey, Google, ask my
fitness app how many miles
have I run today?
Now as Adam C was
talking about, we're
going to run our
natural language
understanding on this phrase.
We're going to extract
out the application
that the user is asking about.
We're also going to extract
out the fact that they're
talking about an intent that
maps over to the get exercise
observation action.
Well, they're going to
look at the text of that
and we're going to find out
that they're talking about how
many miles that they've run.
And we're going to be able
to extract out the structure
parameters of running for
the activity and distance
for the exercise property.
Then we can populate those
parameters into the URL.
You can see here what the final
deep link URL will look like.
HTTPS://yoursite.com/stats
with exercise set to running
and property set to distance.
I think it's pretty neat
how we're able to do that.
Now some of you might
have noted there's
some additional information
in this user's request--
the word today.
This is going to
be a time period
that the user is talking about.
But can we handle that, as well?
And the answer is yes, you can.
Some actions support these
kinds of parameters, as well.
And this one does.
Now I didn't show
it in the actions
that xml was showing before.
But if we had more space,
we could expand and add
an additional parameter
mapping blocks to map
to the start time and end time.
We can then update a
urlTemplate like you see here.
And then now, when the
user says the word today,
it maps through to
those parameters for us,
expanding it into
the actual values
that we can use in our app.
We can see at the bottom
that start date and end date
have now been set for us
with the date of today,
May 8, 2019, at the start of
the day and the end of the day.
OK.
Coming back to our
actions xml, there's
one additional attribute
I wanted to call out.
That's the required
equals true attribute
that you can set on
the parameter block.
This does exactly
what you'd expect.
It means that you
absolutely require
this particular parameter to
be set by the users phrase.
If not, this fulfillment
block will be skipped,
and the next fulfillment
block below it will be tried.
Now this has a couple
of implications.
It means that you must
always have something
called a fallback fulfillment.
That's a fulfillment at the
bottom of your action block
that can pick up any
action that the user says
that doesn't match one of the
previous fulfillment blocks.
The other implication is
that by default, required
is going to be set to false.
And that must mean
that your app should
be prepared to receive that
parameter with no value set.
OK.
So how does this all come
together in your Android
Application well,
the great thing
here is now we're just going
to use standard Android
APIs to receive and
understand those parameters.
Here you can see some example
code from an activity.
We're going to read
the intent that was
used to start that activity.
We're going to read
the data URI that
was used to start the activity.
And we're going to
extract those properties
that we set in the
parameter mapping block,
using getQueryParameter.
You can see here we're
extracting the exercise
and property values.
Now at this point, it's
really up to your application
as to what to do next.
You could go and pre-populate
a bunch of entry fields
and then have a big
button ready for the user
to go and execute that action.
OK.
Coming back to a similar example
to what Adam C showed earlier
in his section, at this
stage of the implementation,
Assistant is able to fulfill
a request by deep link.
The user asks the
Assistant a query.
We run our natural language
understanding on the query.
It identifies which
App Action to call--
get exercise
observation, for example.
It extracts those
structured parameters.
It looks at the
actions of that xml
from the application to find
the right fulfillment block.
It gets that urlTemplate.
It substitutes in
the parameters.
It calls through to the Android
application, which opens up.
And then the Android application
processes those parameters
and is able to execute
that action for the user.
Now this is a good
point to call out
our sample that we published on
GitHub, the fit action sample.
You can get it today on the
Actions on Google GitHub
repository.
It's a really good example of
how all this flow that I just
talked about works end to end.
OK.
One additional feature I
want to talk about in Step 2,
inline inventory.
This is where you can
optionally tell the Assistant
about unique values in your app.
Inline inventory is a
lightweight way for you
to customize the parameter
values that your app expects
to receive from the Assistant.
Now this makes
sense where you have
a kind of finite list
of possible values
a good example might be a
restaurant's list of menu
items, because they would be
unique for each restaurant
and finite in length.
We've been working with
Dunkin' in early access
to test a lot of this out.
So let's look at an
example from them
to illustrate how this works.
The user may say something
like, hey, Google,
order a blueberry crisp ice
signature latte from Dunkin'.
Now the user may say
that phrase and we'll
be able to extract
the text from it.
But of course, the user may say
it in a slightly different way.
They're not always going to
get that exact product name.
Inline inventory will let us
tell the Assistant about what
values to expect and
subsequently make
it easier to handle within
our Android application.
Let's look at an
example to illustrate.
Back inside our
actions.xml, we've
defined something you'd
call an entity set.
And we've given it
an ID of menu items.
It's that ID that we're
going to use to link back
to the parameter
mapping block that I
was talking about earlier.
Within our entity set, we can
define a number of entities.
I've shown to here's an example.
Each entity has
three attributes.
There's an identifier, which
is a unique idea that you
give to that particular entity.
There's a name, which is the
canonical name for that entity.
Here, we've given
it an Android string
resource called blueberrylatte.
And then there's an optional
ultimate name attribute,
which is an array
of strings where
you can define alternate
names or synonyms
for that particular entity.
Here we've given it an Android
resource, blueberry synonyms.
Now for the Android
developers in the room,
you'll note that the nice thing
about using Android resources
is that by default, out of the
box, we'll get localization.
So if these entities
have different names
or different synonyms
for different countries
or languages, you can define
them in your Android resources
as you normally would and
we'll pick them up for you.
Let's have a look
inside a strings.xml
that would match with this.
As you can see, we defined
the canonical names
for these two entities,
blueberrylatte and
caramelcrazelatte.
And then we've defined
a number of synonyms,
as well, that would go with
those blueberry synonyms
and caramel craze synonyms.
OK.
But what does this actually get
us if we go and implement it?
Well, now the user
can say something
like, hey, Google, order a
blueberry crisp iced signature
latte from Dunkin'.
Or they could say, hey, Google,
order a blueberry iced coffee
from Dunkin'.
And Assistant will be able
to extract out those names,
match it against our
entities that we defined,
and convert it over
to the unique ID
that we defined in
our actions.xml.
In this case, the ID
was 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 8.
We're then going to
pass that unique ID over
to your Android
application instead
of the name of the product.
And you can quickly use that to
show the user the right thing
in your application
and get the user
to be able to complete
that action quicker.
You can see an example of this
in action on the right here.
All right.
That was a lot of
information for Step 2.
I'm going to move
along to Step 3,
optimizing app
for the Assistant.
In this step, we ask
that you implement
three additional APIs.
Why?
This is really to help Assistant
gain additional understanding
of your application and
of your App Actions.
I'm going to walk
through each one, what
it is, why it's
needed, and go over
the implementation quickly.
OK.
The first one is logging
a result via Firebase.
So what is this?
Well, as Google Assistant
loses visibility
of what happens after the user
is taken over to your Android
application, we
ask that you send
us a simple success
or failure signal
so that we know if the user
was successful in completing
that App Action.
Why do we need this?
So we can be confident in
continuing to send users over
to your Android application.
Because without
this, we wouldn't
know if the user is having
a good experience or not.
Implementation requires that
you first set up your Android
application for Firebase.
Then in your build.gradle file,
go in and add a dependency
to the app indexing library.
Now I'm not going to talk
about app indexing in depth
in this talk.
But for those of
you who know it,
you might be thinking,
whoa, do I need to go
and actually implement all of
app indexing to implement this?
And the answer is no.
We're only going to use a very
small part of the app indexing
library, a set of APIs called
the Firebase user actions APIs.
And the entire code for
how you implement this
is seen on this slide.
Here we're in our
activity and we've
defined a function called
notifyActionSuccess.
This takes a single parameter
of if that particular app
action was successful or not.
The first thing
we're going to do
is look at the intent that was
used to start this activity
and extract off a
special token extra.
You can see that
highlighted here.
This is a special
token that we pass over
from the Assistant to Android
application in that deep link
intent.
Next we're going to call upon
a special AssistActionBuilder
class from the Firebase
[INAUDIBLE] library.
We're going to set
that token and we're
going to set the status, the
success or failure status.
Then we're going to call
the FirebaseUserActions API
and we're going to call
a special method end
and pass in that action.
Now you might be thinking,
what is this end?
Like, why am I calling
it end all of a sudden?
Well, FirebaseUserActions
works like this.
It has a start,
and it has an end.
The start signifies the
start of the action.
But in this case, that happened
over in the Google Assistant.
End signifies the
end of the action,
and that's going to happen
in your Android application.
After that, we're going to
call NotifyActionSuccess,
the function that we
created along with
STATUS_TYPE_COMPLETED if
that app action completed
successfully or
STATUS_TYPE_FAILED if it
didn't.
OK.
Next one, handling
something called
the Search Common Intent.
This is actually an
existing Android API
and the developer
documentation has
been up on the docs for
quite a while already.
But what is this, if you're
not familiar with it?
Well, it lets your app respond
to a generic search query.
For example, the user may say,
hey, Google, search for sushi
on my restaurant app.
This would allow
the My Restaurant
app to open up, and be passed
the term sushi, after which it
could run a particular
search query
within the app for that term.
Why do we need this?
Well, it's utilized
by App Actions
basically as a fallback
to provide a better user
experience when things may
not go according to plan.
But we still have
a high confidence
that the user wants to
use your application.
Implementation is
quite straightforward.
First of all, go to
your Android manifest
and add a new intent filter
to either an existing activity
or create a new activity.
Set the action to
what you see here--
com.google.andro
id.gms.actions.SEARCH_ACTION.
And set category default
like you normally would.
Then in your
activity, you're going
to use standard APIs
to read the intent that
was used to stop the
activity and check
the action matches the action
we set in our manifest.
We're going to read off
a special string extra,
SearchIntents.EXTRA_QUERY, which
is going to be that search term
that I was talking about before.
And then at that point,
kind of like before,
it's really up to your
app as to what to do next.
If you have a search
screen in your application,
you're probably going to want to
open that up, populate the text
entry field, and execute
the search for the user.
The third API that I'm going
to talk about, the Assist API.
Now this one has also actually
been around for a little while.
It's an existing Android API
and is already documented
on our Developer website.
What is this?
Well, this provides
the Assistant
additional information
about what's currently being
displayed by your application.
And why do we need this?
Well, it allows us to offer
a better user experience
when the users invoke the
Assistant or App Actions while
already using an application.
Now you might be
thinking, well, when
is the user using my
application and calling it up
on the Assistant?
Well, hopefully you saw the cool
demos of the next generation
Assistant and you can
see what the future holds
for the Assistant, where
it can be everywhere
and can help you no
matter what kind of task
you're trying to achieve.
So you can see where an API like
this would come in really handy
for something like that.
But even today, if you
long press the Home button
on many Android devices,
it'll call up your system
as an overlay on top of whatever
the user is currently doing.
It's at that point
that this API gets
called to get additional
information about what's
currently on the screen.
To implement this inside
a particular activity,
override a method called
onProvideAssistContent.
This takes a single parameter
of type Assist Content.
And what we ask that you set
is in the structured data
field of this object, set
a special JSON-LD object
based on Schema.org markup.
We have more details
of exactly the values
you should be setting on
our developer website.
But as an illustration,
here you can
see we're setting a
schema.org type of menu item.
And then we're saying
the name parameter
to blueberry crisp
iced signature
latte, the item that
would be showing
on the screen at
a particular time.
Finally, if we use App Actions--
I'm sorry, if we use
Android app links now
for this particular
screen, we're
going to set the
URL appropriately.
All right, that's it for Step 3.
We're almost there.
Stick with me.
Step 4, testing and deployment.
So testing out app actions
is particularly tricky.
Because the
Assistant needs to be
aware on our back end of the
content of your actions.xml.
To facilitate testing, we
created a special App Actions
test tool plug-in
for Android Studio.
It goes and reads your local
development actions.xml,
it passes it, and sends
it up to our back end.
And it creates a special
App Actions preview
just for the Google
account that's
logged into Android Studio.
Then on your test
devices, as long
as you are logged in with
the same Google account,
you can immediately
test those App Actions.
Now it's worth noting that
that Google account must also
have access to that package
name in the Google Play Console
so that we know
that you're an owner
of that particular package.
See a screenshot of the
test tool on the left.
Now it might be
hard to make out.
But what you can see is
an App Actions preview
has been published.
You can configure a
particular App Action
that you've defined
in your actions.xml.
You can set test values for the
parameters that you defined.
Then it generates a
special ADB command
that can go and test that
in the Google Assistant
and call through to Android app.
You can click Run to run
it on a device that's
connected to your
machine immediately,
or you can click Copy to copy
the ADB command to use it
in test scripts or a
CI system, for example.
And finally deployment, as
Adam C mentioned earlier,
you can start developing
App Actions today.
And it'll go live for end
users later this year.
To get started, first
make sure you've
completed the form on
our developer website
so that we know that you're
building App Actions.
When it comes to
deployment time,
you're going to upload
your regular Android app
binary, your APK, or
your Android app bundle
to Google Play Console
as you normally would.
We're then going to extract
out that actions.xml
and send it over to our
Actions on Google back end
to be processed.
Now, it's worth noting that
there is a manual review
process that will take
place on your App Actions
to ensure a great
user experience.
But this review process will not
affect the regular Android app
review timelines and deployment
status in Google Play.
OK.
That was a lot of information.
Let me quickly recap
the implementation.
Step number one, supporting
deep links in your Android app.
Step number two,
telling the Assistant
how to take advantage
of those deep links
and use your app via
the actions.xml file.
Step number three,
optimizing your app further
for the Google Assistant
by implementing
the three APIs I talked about.
And then finally, testing, using
the Studio test tool plug-in
and deploying via
the Play Console.
[APPLAUSE]
SOFIA ALTUNA: All right.
So now that you've
seen all of the steps
for implementing App Actions,
you know how quick and simple
it is.
As a user, I also find
it really refreshing.
Now I can begin my app
journeys with voice
and fast forward a couple of
steps into the right actions
and content that I want to see.
Here are a few examples from
some of our early developers.
As the Adams were
showing us before, I
can start tracking my run
with no taps and no clicks
simply by saying, hey,
Google, start my run
with Nike Run Club.
I can as easily order food from
some of my favorite apps, book
a ride, or even check my
financials, whether that's
my account balance, my
bills, my investments,
or even send money to
a friend using PayPal.
Again, these are
just a few examples
from some of our
early developers
within the first four
categories that we're
going to be launching.
And as we've
mentioned today, you
can also get started
building actions like this
from within your Android apps.
Simply by creating
a single .xml file,
you can actually
get started today.
You can enable your users to
discover, re-engage, and invoke
your apps by voice
across multiple touch
points in Android.
But that's not all.
Because for simple
answers, wouldn't it
be nice to give those answers
directly in the Assistant?
So I see some heads
nodding, so great.
We think so, too.
So in this next
session, I'll talk
about how you can bring
some of your app content
into the Assistant.
So let's go back to that
initial example with Nike
that Adam mentioned.
Adam started his run by coming
to the Assistant and saying,
hey, Google, start my
run with Nike Run Club.
When he finished
his run, he then
came back to the Assistant.
And this time he asked for how
many calories he has burned.
Now you're going to see
that this information is
being displayed directly in
the Assistant via a Slice.
So let's pause this
video and break it down
into all the four steps.
In the initial
action, we're purely
deep linking Adam into the Nike
app to start tracking his run.
However, when Adam then
comes back to the Assistant
and asks for how many
calories he's burned,
Nike is displaying a piece,
or a slice of their app,
directly on the
Assistant via Slices.
Slices are part of App Actions.
They're essentially the visual
representation and enhancement
of this feature.
For queries that are
one shot, like this one,
we recommend building Slices so
that you can display the answer
inline on the Assistant so
that your users don't have
to take any additional steps.
Some people call Slices the
modern successor of Android app
widgets that you may
have already added
to your home screen.
And they're right.
Slices our UI templates
that can display
rich, dynamic, and interacting
content from your app
directly on the Assistant
or even a Google search.
Through these
templates, we're going
to provide you with a flexible
and rich mode of expressing
your app that's also
predictable and dependable.
Slices can also be interactive.
These templates
house many components
to enable anything from
rich content preview
to inline one shot answers.
If you want to learn
more about Slices,
please go to our website at
g.co/Slices or go on YouTube
and see our last year's
I/O talk on this topic.
The best part about
Slices is that it's
super easy to implement.
You simply have to
make two changes when
creating your actions.xml file.
First, you have to change the
fulfillment mode to Slice.
And second, you have to update
the urlTemplate to Slice
provider instead.
And then, the
urlTemplate's parameters
will expand into their values
as our second Adam mentioned
before.
[LAUGHTER]
But the one caveat is that
App Actions and Slices only
work on devices where
Android apps are installed.
But as you've seen, Assistant
is in a lot of devices
where apps are not installed.
In this new age of
Assistant, people
have smart speakers, smart
refrigerators, smart vacuums.
You name it.
There's a lot of things
you can talk to nowadays.
And like this, we have many more
new devices and platforms that
are coming onto the market.
Many of these are also
not Android-based.
And sometimes opening
an Android app
may not be the preferred
way your user wants
to engage with your
content at every moment.
So as users turn to many
of these new devices,
this is a new
opportunity for you
to reach them, no
matter where they are,
by creating
Conversational Actions.
Through Conversational
Actions, you
can create custom,
multimodal experiences,
and extend your services to new
form factors and new devices,
combining conversation and rich
UI interactions for the Google
Assistant.
Now Conversational
Actions shouldn't
try to replicate your
entire app on voice.
Instead, you should
focus on identifying
those specific,
unique toothbrush
moments for your
users that can be
accessed across all
Assistant-enabled devices.
With 1 billion plus devices
running on Google Assistant,
you can build a strong
presence at the moment
where your users meet you,
no matter where they are.
If you want to learn more about
how to create Conversational
Actions, please visit one of
our many talks on this topic,
including one here
tomorrow at 2:30 PM
called Designing
Quality Conversations
for the Google Assistant.
And for those of you
who are on livestream,
you can also watch
it live tomorrow.
Let's do a quick recap.
So App Actions, which includes
Slices and Conversational
Actions are both part of the
actions in Google Platform.
When you look at
App Actions, we just
look at it as the first step
in your journey with actions.
It can give you instant increase
in reach and re-engagement
for your apps across
multiple devices
on Android with relatively
low developer effort.
You can also then extend
your brand even further
by creating
Conversational Actions
and making sure that you're
ready to engage with your users
no matter where they are.
So let's put this together
by showing you an example.
I'm a Citibank customer.
So I have their
Android app downloaded.
So when I'm on my phone, I can
check for my account balance
or my bills.
And then I can always click on
Open app to go into their app
and take additional actions.
Now Citibank also created
a Conversational Action.
They've identified one of
those unique toothbrush moments
for their customers
and created an action
that let's you check for
Citi-preferred tickets
to events.
So I'm Latin, if
you couldn't tell.
I live in New York City.
And I love music.
So I can use the Citibank action
to check for Latin concerts
in New York City.
So no matter where I am, whether
I'm driving, I'm at home,
I'm on my phone,
headphones, you get it,
no matter where I am
as a Citibank customer,
I can always reach them across
multiple devices on Assistant.
Lastly, let's see
how all of this
fits together from a high level
architectural perspective.
So if I'm creating
an app, and let's say
for this purpose it's my
exercising health and fitness
app, what I'm going
to do first is put up
a server that will be
connected to my database
where all of my users'
information is stored.
Then I'm going to create my app
that will talk to that server
to get the users'
information and send it
back to my app, which
will render it based
on the UI design of my app.
The same concept works for IOS
and for a web-based interface
to your app.
When you then go to create
a Conversational Action,
you're going to follow
the same process.
What you're going to do first is
create a Conversational Action
that will talk to
your server, using
the same API and the
same infrastructure
that you've already provided.
What happens then is, for
queries, such as how many steps
have I taken today,
the Assistant
will take care of all the
natural language understanding.
It will understand
what the query is
and invoke your action.
Your action will then also
understand what the query is
and fulfill that intent.
In order to fulfill
that intent, you'll
use a web hook,
which will connect
to the server on the back end
to provide the response back
to the Assistant.
The key point here is
that you as a developer
don't need to
rebuild anything new.
You are using the exact
same infrastructure, API,
and identity mechanisms
that you've already
provided to your
app to also provide
a conversational
response to your users
through the Google Assistant.
Essentially, you
have one server.
And you're just
adding a new client,
whether that's your
Android app, iOS, website,
or a Conversational Action.
So with that, hope you're
all as excited as we are.
And no matter what app you
have, you can get started today.
If your app falls within one
of the first four categories
that we've mentioned--
ridesharing, health and fitness,
finance, and food ordering--
you can get started implementing
and testing today by visiting
our website that just went live
yesterday, at g.co/AppActions.
If your app doesn't fall within
one of these four categories,
do not worry.
We have new categories
coming out very soon.
But you can also get started
by optimizing for App Actions
today.
You can start
creating deep links
for some of your key
application moments,
and you can also start
experimenting with Slices.
All of our
documentation is public.
But if there is one link
you need to remember,
it's g.co/AppActions.
For those of you who are here
with us today and this week,
please come visit
us at office hours
and come check out some of our
demos in the Assistant sandbox.
It's literally right
around the corner.
We still have a lot of I/O left.
So we look forward
to seeing you around.
And thank you all so much
for coming this morning.
[APPLAUSE]
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]